مشهد وفاه شابه بادرت بالتبرع لشقيقها
بكليتها في مسلسل كان ظروف اثار جدلا
واسعا في المغرب والسبب رفض ربط التبرع
بالاعضاء بالموت
[موسيقى]
المسلسل درامي الذي يعرض على القناه
المغربيه الاولى يعد من بين الاعمال
الرمضانيه التي تحظى باعلى نسب المشاهده
في المغرب حيث حقق اكثر من خمسه ملايين
مشاهده لكن مشهد وفاه المتبرعه خلف صدمه
بين متابعي العمل الدرامي واخصائه امراض
الكلى الذين عبروا عن رفضهم لتمرير
الرسائل سلبيه من شانها التاثير على عمليه
ووتيره التبرع بالاعضاء في المغرب
[موسيقى]
وتباينت الاراء بين من حذر من خطوره مثل
هذه المشاهد التي قد تؤدي الى العزوف عن
التبرع بالاعضاء ومن اعتبر المشهد ضروره
للفت الانتباه الى اهميه المتابعه الطبيه
بعد اجراء العمليات الجراحيه
كاتب السيناريو المسلسل نفس ان تكون
الوفاء بهدف ترهيب المشاهدين من عمليه
التبرع بالاعضاء بل ربطته بالاهمال الطبي
وفور عرض مشهد موت الشخصيه التي تبرعت
بكليتها سارع عدد من اخصائه امراض الكلى
في المغرب الى طمانه المتابعين حول سلامه
عمليه التبرع داعين الى ضروره تنظيف الفن
والاعلام في المساعده على اشاعه ثقافه
التبرع بالاعضاء